[Musik]
carus beauty und große glocke hallo
leute herzlich willkommen zu meinem
neuen unboxing-video ich bin voll
aufgeregt weil gerade weil er aber sonst
glaube da hat mir den neuen
koalitionsvertrag gebracht jetzt schaue
ich mal ob da auch was für lebende
menschen drin steht also die unter 60
also am meisten profitieren doch die
alten ein rentner haushalt bekommt im
jahr bald 622 euro mehr
eines kann ich den total meine um jetzt
läuft die 622 meine omi aber kaum was
für junge leute dabei kiffen bleibt
weiter illegal aber außenwerbung für
zigaretten dort erlaubt aber das wollten
wir schon abschaffen des stands aber
hier drin ja aber dann ist das verbot in
letzter minute rausgeflogen weil wohl
anscheinend einer von den politikern die
mit der tabaklobby ist ja aber es wäre
unseriös zu sagen wer genau das ist aber
es ist auf jeden fall volker kauder ich
alles schlecht
jetzt gibt's bald baukindergeld ist dass
der bahnhof als ich meine ich wollte
keine kinder aber jetzt heißt es
natürlich fick dich ins eigenheim
so und jetzt kommt der absolute mega
oberhammer die groko kümmert sich
endlich um
computerspiele was also wir wollen beim
thema computerspiele auch dafür sorgen
dass computerspiele endlich den
stellenwert bekommen dem sie schon
längst haben sollten ja bravo endlich
hilft mal einer sony und nintendo und es
gibt jetzt sogar schon das game zum
koalitionsvertrag grand theft auto 3
beinharte action kämpfe um die coolsten
ministerien
als nahles zwölf stunden lang beleidigt
am tisch bis deine gang endlich das
finanzministerium hat oder noch mehr
action spiel seehofer und 5000 mandarin
entscheide scheiße und dann steht jedoch
der lustigste satz level die groko plant
für deutschland den sprung in die
achtung weltspitze der dig it
infrastruktur
ich meine mit unserem kag internet hier
kann man ja auch nicht machen ruckelfrei
oder sich vernünftigen pornos
carus beauty und groupware carolina